ROB DODSON: ES6 generators
will take the pain out
of asynchronous programming.
And what happens when you ask
a neural network what it sees?
I'm Rob Dodson.
This is LazyWeb.
ES6 generators will
dramatically simplify the way
we write asynchronous code.
JAFAR HUSAIN: How many
people understand them?
ROB DODSON: But first, we
have to understand them.
Jafar Husein breaks down the
concepts that power generators,
like iterators and observers,
and demonstrates the power
of asynchronous iteration.
You'll want to watch the video a
few times to grok the examples,
but once it clicks,
you're golden.
MARCY SUTTON: Let's do one
cheese and one pepperoni.
ROB DODSON: Learn
accessibility testing
in the time it takes
to order a pizza.
Marcy Sutton introduces us to
semi-automated accessibility
tools, like Chrome's
a11y audit tool, which
will give your site an
accessibility report card,
as well as fully
automated solutions,
like Angular's
Protractor test runner.
The talk also demonstrates
what a unit test for accessible
attributes should look like.
You can find more info
down in the show notes.
Why should I use SVG?
Because it's a
rainbow of awesome!
In this talk, Chris
Coyier explains the basics
of SVG, and how to
use it for the web.
SVG is a vector
image format that
uses markup instead
of pixels, making
it extremely easy to compress,
and also programmable.
The talk highlights useful
libraries for working with SVG,
tools to incorporate SVG
into your build process,
and a ton of really
awesome CodePen demos.
You can grab the links
down in the show notes.
Artificial neural
networks help us
classify and search for images.
But what happens when
you run them backwards?
A post on the
Google research blog
highlights what
happens when you ask
different layers
of a neural network
to amplify what they
see in a picture.
By switching to
higher level layers,
whole objects seem to emerge,
similar to the human phenomenon
of pareidolia, or
seeing shapes in clouds.
You can get the full
article plus a gallery
of generated images
down in the show notes.
Offline caching means
content is instantly
available on any connection,
but what about pages
that aren't in the cache yet?
In this video, Jake Archibald
demonstrates the new background
sync feature in Chrome Canary.
Background sync let's
you download content even
when the page is not
running in the browser,
and then later notify the user
that their content is ready.
The offline web wins again.
That's it for this week folks.
Links to everything are
down in the show notes.
Click that little
subscribe button.
And to all you lazywebbers out
there, thanks for watching.